Bonjour!
J'avais dit que je ferais sûrement une pause
de Chroniques de Prof pendant l'été et c'est
le cas, mais comme je n'avais pas envie d'abandonner
ma chaîne pendant deux mois j'ai décidé
de réaliser quatre petits épisodes dédiés
à une femme que je trouve particulièrement,
cool, exemplaire, ou tout simplement dont
j'ai envie de raconter la vie.
Elles ont vécut à des périodes diverses
et n'ont aucun lien entre elles, si ce n'est
que ce sont des femmes et qu'on n'en parle
pas assez dans les manuels scolaires! Et
partout ailleurs.
Alors pour commencer, j'ai choisi de vous
présenter Bodicea, que les latins appellent
aussi Boudicca. On connaît sa vie à partir
de deux récits: celui de Tacite et de Dion
Cassius, deux auteurs romains qui ne l'ont
probablement même jamais vue en vrai, n'étaient
pas en Bretagne, on ne peut donc pas prouver
que tout ce qu'ils disent sur elle est vrai.
Pour planter le décor, Boudicca est née
vers 30 après JC, on n'est pas bien sûrs
de la date, et morte en 61 après JC. Cette
fois on est sûrs. Tu sens la fin tragique.
D'après Dion Cassius c'était une reine du
peuple des Iceni, qui vivait dans la région
actuelle du Norfolk à l'Est de la Bretagne.
A l'époque, il s'agissait d'une province
romaine: le beau-père du mari de Boudicca,
qui était roi avant son mari donc, avait
conclu une alliance avec les romains pour
protéger son peuple et ses terres.
Le problème est qu'à la mort du mari de
Boudicca, ce dernier lègue la moitié du
royaume à sa femme et ses filles et l'autre
moitié à l'Empire romain. On ne sait pas
si c'était ce que prévoyaient les lois romaines
ou s'il espérait que l'empereur se montrerait
alors clément avec sa famille: en tout
cas, c'est raté.
Le procurateur romain en charge de ce territoire,
Catus Decianus, en aurait profité pour augmenter
les impôts des Icéniens, piller leurs terres,
etc. Boudicca tente de protester mais elle
est alors fouettée devant son peuple et ses
filles sont violées par des légionnaires
romains.
D'après Tacite, parce que Dion Cassius ne
parle pas de ses filles. Les sources sont
pas super fiables, hein, enregistrez-le:
rien n'est absolument avéré dans cette histoire.
En réaction à ces violences faites à l'encontre
de son peuple et de sa famille, le peuple
des Icéniens se révolte, mené par Boudicca.
Il est possible que d'autres peuples les aient
rejoints, et elle réunit une armée de 120
000 hommes qui ne rencontre pas trop de résistances
au départ puisque les légions romaines de
Bretagne étaient à ce moment là occupées
à faire la chasse aux druides sur l'île
de Mona.
Elle prend rapidement les villes de Camulodunum
(Colchester), Verulamium qui n'a pas d'équivalent
actuel et Londinium, Londres. Dans chacune
de ces villes s'enchaînent massacres et destructions,
il y aurait eu 70 à 80 000 victimes chez
les romains et alliés. Cette fois, les destructions
de ces trois villes sont bien avérées par
les fouilles archéologiques.
Finalement le gouverneur réagit, et envoie
deux légions affronter Boudicca quelque part
entre Londres et Verulamium, dans un lieu
dont on ne connaît pas l'emplacement exact
mais qu'on appelle Watling Street.
D'après Tacite, c'est un massacre: l'armée
de Boudicca perd 80 000 hommes contre 400
chez les romains. Elle meurt peu après cette
bataille, soit en avalant du poison après
avoir compris sa défaite, soit de maladie.
Peu de choses sont donc avérées sur Boudicca:
on ne sait pas non plus à quoi elle ressemblait;
Dion Cassius la décrit comme une rousse à
la chevelure flamboyante, armée d'une lance
et qui terrifiait ses ennemis, mais il a probablement
inventé cette description de toutes pièces.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'une révolte a eu
lieu en Bretagne en 61, et qu'elle a probablement
été menée par une reine appelée Boudicca.
Enfin, Bodicea, rendons-lui son nom d'origine.
Elle nous permet un aperçu des relations
entre les romains et les bretons, à une époque
où les conflits étaient encore fréquents:
la paix romaine n'est pas encore pour tout
de suite.
La légende autour de cette révolte a fait
de Bodicea une sorte de Vercingétorix bretonne:
elle représente la résistance, et connaît
une fin tragique comme Vercingétorix.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, le
prochain sortira dans deux semaines exactement
et fera une bonne avancée dans le temps.
En attendant si vous voulez rester plongé
dans la Bretagne à l'époque romaine, je
vous invite à revoir mon épisode sur le
mur d'Hadrien!
Bonnes vacances et le prochain épisode sortira
après Montbazon, donc je vous retrouverai
peut-être là-bas avant pour certains. A
bientôt!